[Music]
this week is again filled with all sorts
of news from Hollywood while action fans
get updates on The Expendables 4 there
is also a lot of new images available
for the boys and red Sonia moreover you
can learn what Dwayne Johnson has
revealed about an appearance by Superman
in the upcoming Black Adam so stay tuned
and enjoy our new video
there was news about the popular Amazon
series The Boys via Twitter earlier this
week on view are two completely new
soups who should not be familiar even to
Die Hard fans of the comic book series
the reason is obvious because these
superheroes were indeed created
specifically for the show mind you after
24 episodes and three seasons the comic
book original has slowly but surely been
used to the max in the promo images we
see the tick actress Valerie Curry and
Susan Hayward who is best known from
Orange is the New Black while one
embodies the superhero Sage who is said
to already be a thousand steps ahead of
you the other one is firecracker and
stands out for having a short fuse
according to showrunner Eric Kripke we
can look forward to both of them equally
they are supposed to be among the
craziest additions he has made to the
series so far officially it is not known
yet how the story will unfold after the
end of the third season however a
conflict between two main characters
seems likely and the compound b super
serum will definitely play a significant
role as well we are eagerly awaiting
further news though a release date is
sadly not yet in sight
the production of Transformers rise of
the beasts keeps on making great strides
this week two new well-known additions
to the cast were introduced on the one
hand James Bond actress Michelle yo was
presented she has been an essential part
of Hollywood for several years and has
worked on numerous projects over the
past years and decades on the other hand
it was announced that U.S comedian Pete
Davison will take on a role in the
seventh Transformers movie not only is
Davison a regular guest in various
tabloids but meanwhile he is also an
actor frankly he never played Major
roles and he probably won't ever win an
Academy Award either yet his Fame is
beyond dispute especially since he is a
full-time comedian and thus should not
have any trouble with dubbing Davison
voices the role of Autobot Mirage Alias
Dino who can transform into a red
Ferrari 458 and who some may know from
Transformers 3 Michelle
meanwhile dubs the part of the quiet and
self-assured maximal erazor Stephen
cable Jr is in charge of directing the
film and we cannot wait to see the final
outcome the movie is planned for release
on June 9 2023.
Black Adam will finally be released in
cinemas in a few days time after many
years of production particularly due to
the involvement of Dwayne Johnson many
can barely wait to finally seed the Grim
and well-built main character in action
in recent days a conversation between
Johnson and journalist Jake Hamilton
caused quite a stir where the 50 year
old continued to raise Spirits for the
film The two talk about what an
encounter between Black Adam and
Superman would probably look like and
that Black Adam would likely strike the
first blow but definitely not the last
one speaking to Cinema Blend Johnson
also made the point of saying that the
two would definitely clash in an
upcoming film in the dceu he added that
this was also to meet the expectations
of the fans who have been hoping for
such a spectacle for quite some time we
wonder whether we will see The Return of
Henry Cavill after all this has been one
of the biggest fan requests for the cast
of Superman it remains exciting at
present many premieres of Black Adam are
running and the U.S theatrical release
on October 21st is also near as soon as
the hype around Black Adam has died down
we hope to have news about a film
featuring both DC characters
for all MCU fans there was a bit of a
downer this week as Disney surprisingly
announced a number of long-awaited
Marvel movies have been postponed in
some cases quite significantly a proper
reason was not given however we do have
knowledge of creative troubles with
respect to one of the postponed movies
This concerns blade starring mahershava
Ali who is to embody the iconic
character from the comic Universe
shooting was supposed to start next
month however the psalm Tariq decided to
quit his position as director in late
September and take on the role of the
Executive Producer instead given this
news it was only a matter of time before
the release date was officially pushed
back which has now actually been done
what many were not quite aware of though
is that this also messes up the entire
film schedule of the MCU and as a result
not only blade but also several other
films are affected by the postponement
blade is now due for release on
September 6 2024 causing Deadpool 3 to
be pushed back by two months on November
8
2024. we must also wait longer for the
Fantastic Four Adventure which won't be
released until February 14
2025. the last two movies affected
include an as yet unknown Marvel movie
that will be released on November 7th
2025 and Avengers Secret Wars which is
now slated for a May 1st 2026 release
date especially for Avengers fans the
postponement is anything but positive
since both sequels were originally
intended to be released within a short
time of each other in 2025. obviously
this is no longer going to happen as
there is now a year between the two
releases a bitter disappointment for
many MCU fans with such a finicky
scheduling of movies even small changes
have a big impact but at least we won't
have to spend a lot of time waiting for
the next MCU film after all the
theatrical release of the last phase 4
film black panther 2 wakanda forever is
already approaching on November 11th
last week Nintendo released the first
trailer for the upcoming Super Mario
Brothers movie of course the trailer has
made massive waves after all just about
anyone knows the famous Italian plumber
whether from the classic Nintendo
platformer days or from later spin-offs
like Mario Kart when the signing of
Jurassic world star Chris Pratt was
announced some time ago as the voice of
the always cheerful Mario the reactions
were rather positive in the trailer
however Pratt and his character get
little attention with fans instead
admiring the powerful performance of
Bowser voiced by Jack Black sadly
opinions on Pratt's performance are
rather negative finding little approval
among fans despite Pratt's Superstar
status the community misses Charles
martinet who unmistakably breathed life
into the plumber and also dubbed other
characters like Luigi Bowser and Donkey
Kong in addition Pratt speaks without an
Italian accent which certainly sounds
odd at first the second point of
criticism concerns the visuals of Mario
as he looks slightly different from what
many fans have not expected since the
trailer's release many suggestions for
improving the visuals have been
circulating especially on Reddit however
despite all the talk it has to be said
that the discussions surrounding the
Super Mario Brothers trailer are by no
means the equivalent of a shitstorm as
was the case but the first version of
Sonic if anything we are talking about
nitpicking here all in all the movie
adaptation looks visually appealing and
it will be interesting to see what other
promotional content we will get before
the release the Super Mario Brothers
movie is scheduled for release on April
7 2023
this week deadline announced new
information regarding the extremely well
cast The Expendables 4. for a long time
it was unclear when the film would be
released in movie theaters now we know
that a theatrical release is already in
sight on September 22nd 2023 with less
than a year to go in terms of plot The
Expendables 4 is once again about the
well-known mercenary team led by Barney
Ross this time they have to deal with a
current and volatile topic namely a
nuclear conflict between the United
States and Russia the film is sure to be
an action-packed spectacle like the
previous ones with an impressive cast
that fans of the genre can truly look
forward to the cast includes Sylvester
Stallone as Barney Ross Jason Statham as
Lee Christmas Dolph Lundgren as Gunner
Jensen and Randy Couture as toll road
other top stars appear in roles still
unknown including Curtis Jackson AKA 50
Cent and Transformer star Megan Fox for
Stallone this will be his last The
Expendables film in further releases
Jason Statham will assume the role of
the leader of The Expendables the story
was written by moonfall author Spencer
Cohen while Act of Valor director Scott
Waugh was in charge of directing
shooting was already concluded in
December of 2021. a first trailer has
also already been revealed at cinemacon
albeit out of the public eye The
Expendables 4 will hit U.S theaters on
September 22nd 2023 with release dates
in other countries sure to be announced
shortly
Arnold Schwarzenegger ensured that his
role as Conan the Barbarian achieved
worldwide Fame then there was Red Sonja
who also appeared heavily muscled and
fierce another movie about her has been
in the works since the 2000s and people
have been wondering who could possibly
replace Bridget Nielsen as a convincing
actress the answer is Matilda watts and
we actually got a first glimpse of her
character in the past few days apart
from the lead character and her sword
there is not much to see but the overall
impression is much more consistent
compared to the original from 1985. of
course since there are almost 40 years
between the two films a lot has been
done in the area of CGI and visual
effects and thus the trash factor is
totally missing in this picture instead
it gives off a more confident and
serious Vibe all in all a good choice
for a first teaser image that reveals a
certain prevailing mood without giving
away too much unfortunately the latter
also means that we are not able to guess
any details about the plot yet a release
date is still unknown but we will keep
you posted on further updates
now you are up to date with the latest
news from the world of movies and series
but of course we have even more to offer
you besides other amazing videos and
trailers you could watch the Super Mario
Brothers movie trailer if you haven't
done so yet and thus form your own
opinion on the matter wherever it takes
you next we wish you lots of fun
[Music]